على مدار العام الماضي عرضنا في صباح
العربيه العديد من العلاجات الواعده
والتطورات الطبيه في حياتنا لكن تظل كل
هذه العلاجات مرتبطه بشكل كبير بنمط
الحياه الذي نتبعه يوميا تغيير العادات
يمثل تحدي ويتطلب جهد لكن هو ليس مستحيل
تؤكد الاوساط الطبيه ان الخيرات الجيده من
اكل وحركه تؤخر الشيخوخه وتجنبنا الاصابه
بالامراض بالحتي تمكنا من تحدي بعض
الامراض في فقرتنا اليوم نعرض مفاتيح
للحفاظ على صحتنا في 20 23 لتحسين طاقاتنا
عدم الشعور بالقلق والنوم بشكل افضل بشكل
جديد مع علاء
مجله فورس وضعت خمسه اتجاهات للرعايه
الصحيه في عام
2023 اولها مزيدا من استخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي في الرعايه الصحيه سواء لاكتشاف
الادويه او التنبؤ بنتائج التجارب
السريريه ستزيد الرعايه الصحيه المقدمه عن
بعد بشكل ملحوظ كالاستشارات الطبيه عن بعد
والعمليات باستخدام الروبوتات عن بعد ايضا
وفقا للباحثين سيتضاعف كذلك حجم اعمال
الرعايه الصحيه التي انتشرت خلال فتره
كورونا مثل الفحوصات الطبيه السريعه بل
يمكن ان تقدمها امازون وغيرها من الشركات
مثلا
وسنستخدم الاجهزه الطبيه القابله للارتداء
بشكل اكبر مثل الساعات الذكيه وغيرها
واخيرا ستركز العلاجات المقدمه على حسب
نوع الجينات في جسم الانسان
امارس الرياضه باستمرار الاكل الصحي
عم نخفف من الزيوت والاشياء هاي كلها
الواحد يحاول انه يهدي نفسه بهالعمر هذا
ويبعد عن المشاكل
[موسيقى]
طبعا من بعد
الكورونا اللي غلطت على كل العالم من
اليوم صار الواحد يعمل حساب كثير للوقايه
ليدير باله لكل شيء
طبعا بنصح الكل دائما فحوصات دائما
كل واحد عنده طبيب الشخصي يتوجه ليله
ويعمل فحوصات دائما من بعد الكره انا من
وجهه كثير مشاكل
[موسيقى]
هلا بشكل عام احنا عندنا خطه صحيه طول
السنين مع اولادي ونظام ماشيين عليه هلا
بهذا الوقت من الكرونه واللي عم بصير عم
يعتني مثلا بصحتنا من ناحيه هلا الغذائيه
بعتبر نحن تعدينا مرحله الكرونه كمامات
وقايه صحيه عشان تحسن لازم تحسن جسمك من
الداخل كغذاءك كان فيتامينز اكل صحي
على كلن تنضم لنا في الاستوديو دكتوره
صفاء فاضل اختصاصيه طب الاسره عضو الكليه
الملكيه لطب الاسره في المملكه المتحده
اهلا بك دكتوره معانا نورتي الاستوديو طيب
ما هي ابرز نصائح الخبراء مثل حضرتك حتى
تكون سنه 2023 الصحه صحه نفسيه صحتي اهم
شيء في بدايه كل عام وحضراتكم بخير
من ناحيه التغذيه السليمه اللي احنا
بنحاول قد ما نقدر نقطع الملح والسكر
والتربيه السليمه اللي نشرب سوائل بشكل
كامل في تقريبا ثلاثه لاربع لتر يوميا
بحاول ااه نعزز وجود الاوميجا 3 وتواجدها
في التغذيه بتاعتنا اوميجا 3 طبعا تتوفر
في الاسماك زي السلمون
والسردين والتونه بتتوفر في الجوز بشكل
متعارف عليه اللي بيشبه كثير الدماغ كمان
موجوده في بذور الشيا بذور الكتان هذه
الاشياء
الورقيات الخضراء نحاول قد ما نقدر ان
احنا نقطع همم المشروبات الطاقه
والمشروبات الغازيه همم بشكل عام همم
التغذيه السليمه هي من اكثر الاشياء اللي
هتحافظ على جسد سليم وعقل سليم همم وهي
اكثر من اكثر الاشياء اللي هتتباعد ما بين
حدوث همم فرصه حدوث الزهايمر والنسيان دول
همم دي اكثر شيء الحاجه اللي بعد كده
الاكثر سايز او الحركه همم بالنسبه
للاكسترسايز او الحاجه هي اكثر من اثباتات
اللي هي من اكثر الاشياء اللي ممكن تقلل
او تمنع حتى حدوث الزهايمر او تقلل فرصه
حدوثه او حتى لو هيحصل الاسباب جينيه ما
انه تبطئ همم فرصه ال- البرجرسنج بتاع همم
يعني الاكل سهل انه ندخل اكل جديد او
عناصر جديده لنمطنا همم الغذائي لكن
المشكله في همم انه نشيل مثل السكر مثل
الملح انه نغير عاداتنا ونمط غذائنا فهي
النصائح هو طبعا اللايف ستايل ودافكيشن
اللي احنا نعدل في نظامنا الغذائي ونعدل
في اللايف ستايل بتاعنا هو ده من اهم
الاشياء اللي هتساعدنا بشكل مباشر يعني
همم
لو لاحظنا انه اصلا طعم الملح او السكر هو
اصلا مساله تعود وهي مش حاجه
بالتدريج حتى لانه همم يعني اللي بياخذ 20
مشروبات الطاقه بالاشياء دول بشكل مباشر
بيقطعها هتبص ايه خلل تقريبا اكثر من
علاقه السكري يوميا فده شيء كويس جدا يعني
فهي الاشياء تبدا تدريجيا ما في اي
اشكاليه ان احنا مثلا نبدا وهمم وعلى
اللون الجراند بتبص تلاقي الامور بشكل عام
انت بتتحول لايف ستايل افضل والصحي همم
كمان الرياضه من الاشياء المهمه جدا همم
المحافظه على الحركه اصلا بمعدل دقيقتين
لكل ساعه يوميا يعني في معدل تقريبا 45
دقيقه في اليوم في اليوم ال 5 ده بيحافظ
على انه ال- ال- الانسان يبقى هلس يعني
وبيحافظ على الوعي الدماغ الحركه بيقلل
فرصه حدوث الزهايمر بيقل فرصه حدوث
النسيان او الاشياء دول همم في المقابل
برده بنبص ل- لانه الاعمال المنزليه اثبتت
ان ال- ال- السيده اللي هي مثلا تتقاعد او
بتكون بالاعمال المنزليه بتاعتها همم
الطبخ كانت طبخ وترتيب والاشياء دول لانه
بتبص تلاقي 21% تقريبا هي هي قللت نسبه
حدوث الخلف او اللي هو ال- ال- الزهراني
او الاشياء دول بنسبه 21% يعني همم
بالنسبه للناس اللي هم ملتزمين بالرياضه
45 دقيقه يوميا همم على سنوات على مدار
النمط حياتنا سريع وساعات مستحيل ندخل كل
هذه العناصر الغذائيه الضروريه للدماء
خصوصا لنا متنا الغذائي في اليوم الى اي
ماذا تنصحين بالمكملات الغذائيه كالاوميجا
هو هو اوبشن بس هو في نفس الوقت احنا همم
مهم جدا ان احنا قبل ما نبدا ناخذ الاغذيه
او ناخذ السبلنتس او اللي هي ال- همم نشوف
هل في عندنا نقص او لا هل في عندنا عوارض
او لا همم لكن لو احنا بناخذه بشكل مباشر
نحاول انه حتى لو لانش بوكس انت بتاخذ
اللانش بوكس بتاعك همم تحافظ على فكره
اللي هي اشياء سهله وفي متناول وموجوده
يعني ال- ال- بذور الشيا
بذور الكتان كل الاشياء دول الاشياء
موجوده في المتناول معنا
وسالمون هي اساسا وجبات ممكن نحافظ عليها
مره او مرتين في الاسبوع هي اشياء كلها في
المتناول بس هي فكره ان احنا نوظفها ازاي
ان احنا نضيف الستايل بتاعنا كيف نغير
يعني ان هي ن- بحس ان هو يكون افضل شيء
يعني شكرا جزيلا نورتينا للدكتوره صفاء
فاضل اختصاصيه طب الاسره عضو الكليه
الملكيه الطب الاسره في المملكه